for you
i hear you got some interesting stories
okay where do you get them from
all right so like
basically
a mixture these stories come from
life experiences
from
my friend's experiences that i'm aware
of okay and then i may add a little
twist on it
i like story time
so so
this is just i was just told okay that
so it's on your your instagram stories
is that what do you do you post so like
do people submit them
no no no no so essentially the way my
answer is set up is that i might see a
meme or a real
with a caption or a picture
and from that i can make up a story
from the story there may be truth in it
and there may be features okay so you
kind of embellish it bit like that yeah
so i make it as general as possible
and then yeah people over the years it
just sort of got
people enjoyed reading it what's the
craziest one you've
embellished or or maybe it was true are
they explicit that's another question um
no wouldn't it well yeah i mean yes or
no
yeah like
it depends what you consider explicit
i've got
um content
let's say i've got single mother type
stories um
going up north you might not know but
the women may be deemed a little bit
easier up north when it comes to getting
them
for a certain demographic of mail
is it your demographic of male 1 my
demographic of male 1
um what else
um
she in men
cheating women
you know
um
all types if i mean if i look
it could refresh my memory i'm just
wondering if you got one you want to
read or something okay i just i was told
let me
let me see
is it like similar
so i've never seen your content before
right um but is it like similar to young
philly's sunday stories
um i wouldn't i wouldn't know actually
i'm not too sure i haven't heard it so
okay so like just show me just showed me
this post this was one of my recent
posts so you've seen this right yeah
yeah so you can see
the at the arch or lack of arch right
yeah
so the
the caption on it is women will make you
wait 76 business days for this bs
right
okay yeah
so
my caption is literally a story
based on this
so do you want me to read it yeah okay
cool
so you're on your third date get closer
to the mic okay my bad is better yeah
all right cool so you're on your third
date listening to her
um
tell you why she hates her ex
and how the girl he cheated on with her
was fat and ugly for the third time
as if it as if that stopped the man then
before
you continue to look like you're
interested as you ain't beat
as you ain't beat yet and you throw in
some oh my days swear downs and what no
way mad ting for decoration
another three-figure bill has landed on
the table and all of a sudden her phone
is
is out and her bladder is loose
her
i'm just getting toilet babe hold up
you
yeah yeah cool now you're watching her
sway towards the lavatory and she has
the audacity to take her empty purse
with her
your bank balance and your crypto wallet
have decreased significantly in that
space of time
but the bill is settled and now you're
both in the back of the uber getting
touchy feely huh
oh my god you are you hard you what do
you expect you've made me wait 76 days
[Laughter]
well you ain't got away any longer
whispers i'm already wet and my [ __ ]
shaved you damn her yep it's bolder than
tyrese
you
a yo boss man i beg you paul i bet you
put your foot down boss man obliges with
a smile and three minutes later you're
back at the estate in in your room
huh why do you have two single beds
you i share the room with my little
brother still
her oh okay and where is he
you at his dad's her oh you don't have
the same dad you no
her okay where's your mum
you at her boyfriend's or something
you oh i thought you live with your mum
and dad
you i do
a loud these questions and bend over in
it i like it when you're aggressive you
bend like this her
like this babe you nah just arch it a
piece huh
okay like this baby you
know the other way her oh like this vape
aggressively tries to put
her in position
are you thumb
arch your back brother
oh like this fake you
just lie on your back
oh my god are we going to make love
you you know what just put your pen back
on her why baby oh your willy's gone
soft you mumble should have stayed with
my girl
shaking my head
yo
all right that is not enough sunday
stories but that is elite
so yeah that
that sort of stuff
that i do
or i can just give my own point of view
about you know
like i think you saw the one the longer
you stay single the more they [ __ ] your
future wife
hell the hell close to home
that one is definitely one that hurts
you know
hey the game's the game game is the game
man
charge it to the game people charge it
to the game
okay have it okay question good have you
ever had a girl cheat with you
as in she was cheating on somebody else
yeah yeah yeah what i've heard from guys
is like
that
getting women kind of ruined them
because they saw the awful things women
did with them
exactly that is probably the biggest
factor and it's always the girls like
you wouldn't expect is what they would
say
but that biggest factor so i'm curious
because guys always say you can tell if
she's a hoe but they'll also say like
it's always the ones you didn't expect
so
what what's which one's true
um both statements are true okay
definitely but
i feel like people get into stuff
you know
alcohol being a social lubricant
and
people just
really wanting to do bad stuff
you know
and like we were talking about earlier
men and women both like sex
so when you have that dynamic
whatever can go wrong will go wrong